bonjour j'ai pas ce round un peu mégalo
et fulbert pour présenter ses meubles on
ne voit que ça paie il est vrai que son
métier est né avec cette femme siècle et
la société de consommation
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le mobilier
urbain nocere surtout qu aux gens qu'ils
vendent branché phillips co star que
vous l'êtes vous êtes décorateur
d'intérieur vous avez fait les bains
douches le café costes nous fait des
pâtes des ponts pour vous c'est quoi le
style branché en décoration a le style
branché je ne sais pas ce que c'est je
crois qu'à un moment il ya quelque chose
qui qui résonne avec la société qui
fonctionne que les gens considèrent
comme comme un moyen de communication au
show télé star vous êtes attaqués aux
pattes je suppose que les raisons de ce
choix ne sont pas purement alimentaire
aux mots je m'attaquais tout dans la
mesure où je suis curieux et et je
travaille cette âme et d'expression ou
en fait le design architecture
m'intéresse pas c'est surtout à
travailler symbolique comment finalement
arrivé à manger de la création faire que
la création soit partout et ça ça tu as
ça me paraît bien et tout à fait
cohérent avec notre époque aussi tout ce
que je fais du domaine à l'évidence
le spectacle fait partie de l'évidence
il y à il y a un esprit stark
mais je me défends d'avoir un style car
le style c'est le début de la mort au
chaud